The Goldfinch enthralled readers after its
Pulitzer-winning release as an acclaimed novel,
and now it's poised to have the same effect
on filmgoers as it arrives in theaters in
2019.
Wondering when you can see it, who's starring
in it, and who's behind the camera?
Here's everything you need to know.
Fans of Donna Tartt's work have grown accustomed
to waiting — her shortest gap between novels
is the ten-year drought that spanned between
her 1992 debut The Secret History and its
follow-up, The Little Friend — so the fact
that The Goldfinch has taken six years to
make its way to the big screen is almost to
be expected.
"I've tried to write faster and I don't really
enjoy it.
I don't enjoy the process of doing it, I've
tried to speed up."
But for those who've been eager to see this
story brought to life in theaters, that patience
will soon be rewarded: The Goldfinch is scheduled
to arrive on September 13th, 2019.
A fall release date for a major motion picture
tends to signal the studio's belief that the
film in question could be a contender during
awards season.
After blockbuster season fades in August,
audiences tend to be in the mood for more
serious fare — and awards voters are also
more likely to remember a movie that earned
acclaim later in the year.
Whether this confidence pays off after critics
have their say remains to be seen, but this
release date bodes well for the way studio
execs feel about The Goldfinch.
When it came time to cast The Goldfinch's
main character, Theo, the minds behind the
film knew they would have to cast someone
who could shoulder every bit of the protagonist's
intense, harrowing emotional journey — and
thanks to a breakout role in a 2017 summer
hit by Edgar Wright, Ansel Elgort ended up
nabbing this huge role.
The actor had been making waves for some time,
appearing in films like The Fault in Our Stars
and the Divergent film series, but according
to Variety, it was his quiet yet emotional
turn in Baby Driver that got him enough attention
to book the role of Theo.
Elgort and The White Queen's Aneurin Barnard
will serve as the film's two main stars, and
the rest of the cast is appropriately A-list.
Perhaps the biggest name is Oscar- and Emmy-winning
star Nicole Kidman, who has won critical acclaim
for everything from Moulin Rouge to Big Little
Lies.
You'll also see Emmy winner Sarah Paulson,
known for her work on American Horror Story,
as well as recognizable faces like American
Horror Story's Denis O'Hare, Old School's
Luke Wilson, and Stranger Things actor Finn
Wolfhard.
With the film rights up for sale, Hollywood
started vying in earnest for the chance to
score Tartt's first-ever adaptation, and in
2014 — a year after the book's release and
shortly after it won the Pulitzer Prize — a
major studio stepped in to purchase the rights
for The Goldfinch.
According to Deadline, the book, which at
this point had spent dozens of weeks on The
New York Times' bestseller list, was snapped
up by Warner Brothers Studios in conjunction
with RatPac Entertainment.
It made sense at the time for Warner Brothers
to pick up the rights, especially since they
had previously purchased the rights to The
Secret History, which was never made into
a movie.
With The Secret History still awaiting development
and its award-winning successor primed for
the screen, The Goldfinch became the immediate
focus.
When it came time to choose a director for
The Goldfinch, the studio settled on John
Crowley, an Irish director with a strong background
in theater.
Crowley's breakout film came in 2003 with
Intermission, which won several filmmaking
awards in Ireland, but he hit even bigger
with 2015's Brooklyn, an Academy Award nominee
for Best Picture.
An enormous awards season hit, Brooklyn even
won the BAFTA for Best British Film.
Considering Crowley has plenty of experience
directing personal yet epic stories that span
years and continents, it seems only appropriate
that he would be the right choice for The
Goldfinch, a film which makes its way across
the world while still remaining introspective
and personal.
In 2017, Warner Brothers announced that it
was teaming up with Amazon Studios to partner
on The Goldfinch, meaning Amazon would invest
a significant chunk of the film's budget — reportedly
totaling close to $40 million, according to
Variety — in exchange for streaming rights
on their Prime service after the film's theatrical
release.
Though many studios aggressively lobbied to
be a part of this partnership, Amazon won
out, and that may be due to more than their
sizable financial contribution.
Thanks to Manchester by the Sea, an Amazon
Studios-produced indie that scooped up multiple
Academy Awards, the streaming service became
the first to score an Oscar nomination for
Best Picture, which could only potentially
bode well for The Goldfinch's future.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.